Як вам така послуга – замовити собі дитину?
Це каталог однієї з кліник в Україні
Донорські яйцеклітини, штучне запліднення, сурогатні матері
Залежно від договору, це може коштувати 30, 40 або 50 тисяч євро.
Це дорожче, ніж авто середнього класу,
і це жахливо
Цей вебсайт зробили для німецьких жінок, які не можуть мати дітей
Намагаюся вийти на посередників через Фейсбук
Загалом вони дуже скептично поставилися до того
що до групи приєдналася журналістка
і почала ставити питання
Відповіла лише одна жінка
Вона шукає сурогатну матір,
яка могла би народити їй дитину
Як довго ви шукаєте?
Вона назвалася Сандрою,
обличчя показувати не хоче
Те, що вона шукає - сурогатне материнство -
у Німеччині заборонено
Адже це щось природне, що може кожна жінка
Кожна жінка може мати дитину, але не ми
Наша єдина можливість - це сурогатне материнство
Чому нам це забороняють?
Сандра та її чоловік хочуть зробити штучне запліднення
за допомогою сурогатної матері
яка виносить дитину і отримає за це гроші
Саме це забороняє німецьке законодавство
Аргумент простий: влада Німеччини не хоче
щоб жінки в економічній скруті за гроші продавали своє тіло
Тому такі як Сандра змушені шукати
сурогатних матерів за кордоном
В інтернеті можна знайти як авторитетні кліники
так і сумнівні вебсайти з псевдосурогатними матерями
які вимагають гроші наперед
Утім, Сандра хотіла знайти сурогатну матір
саме у Німеччині
а не за кордоном, і намагалася
робити це через Facebook
Ви торгуєтеся? І якщо так, то про яку суму йдеться?
Є сурогатні матері, які просять 25 тисяч євро
Це максимальна сума?
Ціна може бути вищою
Тут немає максимальної суми
Я говорила з жінкою, яка хотіла
щонайменше 35 тисяч євро
За таку ж суму я можу і за кордоном
знайти сурогатну матір
Сурогатне материнство
в низці інших країн є легальним
Наприклад, у США такі послуги
коштують 100 тисяч євро
в Україні, Лаосі або Кенії - набагато менше
Особливо великий ринок сурогатних матерів в Індії
У 2015 році тамтешній уряд заборонив жінкам
виношувати дітей для жінок з-за кордону
Тепер сурогатне материнство в Індії
хочуть заборонити
навіть для місцевих заможних жінок
Двадцятичотирирічна Рінку розповіла нам
що за вагітність вона заробила стільки ж
скільки її чоловік заробив за сім років
роботи як водій таксі
Тепер вона може відправити вчитись
до школи власних дітей
Ринок стрімко розвивається
і, за оцінками, має обіг
у понад два мільярди доларів
Це вже просто не по-людськи
Це здирництво якесь...
В Україні, розповідає жінка,
вона мала би заплатити 35 тисяч євро
Сурогатна матір отримує лише сім тисяч,
решта - прибуток кліники
Зрештою Сандра та її чоловік таки знайшли
молоду жінку в Німеччині
яка погодилася стати сурогатною матір'ю
Штучне запліднення планують зробити восени
але не в Німеччині, а в чеській клініці
Потім жінка виносить дитину і віддасть Сандрі
Сандра заплатить їй 8 тисяч євро
Авжеж, ми намагаємося знайти
лазівку в німецькому законі
У Німеччині заборонено запліднення
сурогатних матерів
Але ми робимо це за кордоном
А потім ми повернемося в Німеччину
І тоді, виходить, мені доведеться
всиновити власну ж дитину
Коли жінка понад усе хоче дитину
моральні аспекти для неї відходять на задній план
Так само як і для сурогатних матерів
для яких це спосіб прогодувати свої родини
Найгірше, що на цьому наживаються
часто треті люди
для яких дитина - це просто дорогий товар